This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The health and growth of a city is an extra-bly linked to water. Clean water must be available and dirty water needs to be removed. The importance of this cannot be overstated, but it's easy for it to escape our notice. The influence of water in our lives is also personal and profound in ways not directly related to infrastructure, and our friends at Pop-Up Magazine have asked storytellers of all kinds, including a figure skater, a submarine captain, a synchronized swimmer, and many more, to talk about their relationship with water in a beautifully crafted story that just delights me in every way.
这里是《99%不可见》。我是罗曼·马斯。城市的健康与发展与水息息相关。我们需要清洁的水，也需要排走污水。水的重要性怎么强调都不为过，但它又很容易被我们忽视。水在我们生活中的影响同样是个人化且深远的，这种影响并不直接关乎基础设施。我们在《Pop-Up Magazine》的朋友们邀请了各行各业的讲述者——包括花样滑冰运动员、潜艇艇长、花样游泳运动员等等——来讲述他们与水的故事，这是一个精雕细琢的故事，在方方面面都让我感到欣喜。
If you listen to our episode that they produced called Take a Walk, then you know the treat that you're in for. From Pop-Up Magazine, here's Haley Howe, On Water. In my most peaceful moments, I'm floating on my back, face pointed to the sun, ears underwater. All I hear is my breath, and the world around me fades into the background. In those moments, I feel weightless, like I could just float up out of the water and into the sky. Growing up in central Texas, a lot of my life revolved around water.
如果你听过他们制作的那期名为《去散步》的节目，你就会知道这次你将大饱耳福。来自《Pop-Up Magazine》的黑利·豪威为您带来《关于水》。在我最平静的时刻，我仰面漂浮在水面上，脸朝着太阳，耳朵浸在水下。我只能听到自己的呼吸声，周围的世界渐渐退居背景。在那一刻，我感觉自己失重了，仿佛可以从水中浮起到天空中。在德克萨斯州中部长大时，我的很多生活都围绕着水展开。
Summer afternoons at the city pool, long, lazy floats down the river, what does water mean to you? We set out to talk to all sorts of people about their relationship with water, and how it affects their lives. We heard from scientists, swimmers, humanitarians, riders, a mermaid, and more. My hope is that before we continue you can go find some water. Hit pause and drive to the ocean if you're on the coast or walk to a nearby pond or creek. Sit by a fountain at the park or just pour yourself a glass of water and listen. We also made a visual field guide to go along with this series. Check it out at popupmagazine.com. All right, let's dive in.
城市游泳池边的夏日午后，在河上悠长而慵懒的漂流，水对你意味着什么？我们开始与各种各样的人交谈，了解他们与水的故事以及水如何影响他们的生活。我们听取了科学家、游泳运动员、人道主义者、骑手、人鱼等等的声音。我希望在我们继续之前，你能去找点水。按下暂停键，如果你在海岸边就开车去海边，或者走到附近的池塘或小溪边。坐在公园的喷泉旁，或者只是给自己倒一杯水然后静静聆听。我们还制作了一份与本系列配套的视觉野外指南。请访问 popupmagazine.com 查看。好了，让我们深入了解吧。
My name is Barbara Eisen White. I live in Bronx, New York. I'm 85 years old. I belong to the Harlem, Honey, and Bear synchronized swim team. I should make a correction. Senior synchronized swim team. First of all, I've always wanted to swim. I've always been afraid of the water. I'm one of these people that never let the water get in my face, even when I took a shower. And what happened was my son was forced to take a swimming class to get certain credits.
我叫芭芭拉·艾森·怀特。我住在纽约布朗克斯。我今年85岁。我属于哈林甜心与小熊花样游泳队。我得纠正一下。是老年花样游泳队。首先，我一直想游泳。我一直都很怕水。我是那种连洗澡时也从不让水溅到脸上的人。后来发生的事是，我的儿子为了修满某些学分，被迫去上游泳课。
And I had to take him there. And naturally, I enrolled in the adult class. And the first thing the instructor did was take us down to the 12 feet, forced us to go down as far as we could, and see if we bob up again and we did. And from then on, I lost the fear. And most people on the team have the same story, fear of the water. I love to do the pyramid. It's so precise.
我不得不带他去。理所当然地，我也报名了成人班。教练做的第一件事就是把我们带到12英尺深的水区，强迫我们尽可能往下潜，看看我们能不能自己浮上来，而我们确实浮上来了。从那时起，我就克服了恐惧。队里的绝大多数人都有着相同的经历，那就是怕水。我喜欢做金字塔形队列。这非常精准。
We go from one end of the pool to the other, synchronized. And then we take an encore. I feel light free. Just with no problems, no phone calls, nobody calling me. Just my time, my time. And I've heard people say, oh, those old people in the water, they don't know what they're doing.
我们整齐划一地从泳池的一端游到另一端。然后我们进行返场表演。我感到轻盈、自由。没有任何烦恼，没有电话，没有人呼唤我。这只是我的时间，属于我自己的时间。我听人说过，哦，那些在水里的老头老太太，他们根本不知道自己在做什么。
But when they see us, they can't believe it. I'm Tobi Clark and I have been around water, in water, and loving water my entire life. The way that my body feels in water makes me kind of forget that I have a body. There's kind of like being a kid that like covers their eyes and says, you can't see me, like you can see them,
但当他们看到我们时，简直难以置信。我是托比·克拉克，我的一生都与水为伴，在水中度过，并且热爱着水。我的身体在水中的感觉让我几乎忘记了自己拥有一个身体。这有点像小孩子捂住眼睛说“你看不到我”，就像你能看到他们一样，
but to them, they've disappeared. There's this thing where even if people can see me, I don't care, I lose the sense of self-consciousness and the sense of self-consciousness and the sense of self-awareness almost and just kind of become part of the water. Because I'd always kind of felt different around my gender, water was kind of a refuge for me. When I'm in water, I feel incredibly graceful, I feel weightless, I feel competent in my body. Except it's not even like a feeling of competence while I'm doing it, it's just a feeling of being. Growing up in Hawaii, I was very clearly gender non-conforming. I just did not
但在他们眼里，自己已经消失了。有一种现象是，即便别人能看到我，我也毫不在乎，我失去了自我意识，几乎失去了自我察觉，几乎融入了水的一部分。因为我对自己的性别一直有一种不同的感觉，水对我在某种程度上成了避难所。当我在水里时，我感到无比优雅，我感到失重，我对自己的身体感到自信。不过这甚至不是在做动作时那种自信的感觉，而仅仅是一种纯粹存在的感受。在夏威夷长大时，我的性别表现明显不符合传统规范。我只是无法
fit in and I would cut high school and like there was a secret way to hop over the fence and get into this part of the river behind the school. My favorite thing to do would be scramble up the rocks, scramble up the river, and walk as far away from people as I could be where I couldn't see a single human being. And it was just me and the river and the birds. And I would catch crayfish and like just be there and play and lay naked in the sun and be a part of the landscape.
融入其中，我会逃学，学校后面有一条秘密的小路可以翻过篱笆进入河的那一段。我最喜欢做的事情就是爬上岩石，溯流而上，尽可能走得远远的，直到看不到任何一个人类。那里只有我和河水以及鸟儿。我会捉小龙虾，就在那里玩耍，赤身裸体躺在阳光下，成为风景的一部分。
It's one of the great mysteries of deep sea biology, you know. We know more about the surface of the moon than we do about the bottom of the ocean, because the moon you can send up a telescope. You know, you can look through that telescope and you can see what the surface looks like. But the ocean, we have all this water that's in the way, and you've got to try and get through that water to see what the bottom of the ocean looks like. So my name is Dr. Rian Waller. I'm an associate professor of marine sciences at the University of Maine, and I'm a deep sea ecologist. So when I see a body of water that I the University of Maine, and I'm a deep sea ecologist.
这是深海生物学的伟大谜团之一，你知道的。我们对月球表面的了解比对海底的了解还要多，因为对于月球，你可以发射望远镜。你知道的，你可以通过望远镜看到月球表面的样子。但对于海洋，有这么多的水挡在中间，你必须努力穿透这些水，才能看到海底是什么样子。我叫里安·沃勒博士。我是缅因大学海洋科学系的副教授，我是一名深海生态学家。所以当我看到一个水体时，我在缅因大学，我是一名深海生态学家。
So when I see a body of water that I've never seen before, one of the things that I like to do is I like to kind of drain the water. I'm really interested in what animals live in the very bottom of the ocean. I'm what's called a benthic biologist. I work on animals that live on the bottom. And so the water is kind of, it's in the way.
所以当我看到一个从未见过的新水体时，我喜欢做的一件事就是把水“抽干”。我非常对生活在海底深处的动物感兴趣。我被称为底栖生物学家。我研究生活在海底的动物。所以水有点像是在挡路。
You want to move that water out of the way to be able to see what the bottom looks like. And so as a deep sea biologist, we often use things called multi-being maps. And these are maps made by sound on board really large research vessels. And these sound waves are sent to the bottom and they bounce off the bottom. They come back to the ship. And then some really fancy computers and math turns them into these beautiful maps. We'll look at these maps we'll see oh this area is really steep and rocky so there we might find animals that like to filter feed because water is
你想把水移开，以便看清海底的样子。因此，作为一名深海生物学家，我们经常使用所谓的“多波束测深图”。这些是由大型研究船上的声纳制作的地图。这些声波被发送到海底，并从海底反射回来。它们返回船上。然后通过一些非常高档的计算机和数学运算，将它们变成这些美丽的地图。我们查看这些地图时会发现，哦，这个区域非常陡峭且多岩石，所以在那里我们可能会找到喜欢滤食的动物，因为水流
often sped up against these areas that are rocky and so we might find corals and we might find enemies and sponges and animals like that and then we'll see other areas that might be kind of sediment waves. So we might see shrimp or maybe some kinds of lobsters. So that's what I kind of think about when I go to a new area that's never been looked at before. I instantly want to know what the bottom looks like. I am so jealous of people that I see in other parts of the country where you can actually see the bottom of the water when you look through it Okay, I'm scared if I can't see my feet in the water just because I don't know what kind of titha is down there I mean that's a real thing. We have Ruka Roo's and titha is around here. You don't know what's living underneath there
通常会在这些多岩石的区域加速，所以我们可能会发现珊瑚、海葵、海绵以及类似这样的动物，然后我们会看到其他可能是沉积物波的区域。所以我们可能会看到虾，或者某种龙虾。这就是当我前往一个从未被探索过的新区域时脑海中所想的。我立刻就想知道海底是什么样子的。我非常嫉妒那些生活在国家其他地区的人，当你透过水看时，居然能亲眼看到水底。好吧，如果我在水里看不到自己的脚，我就会害怕，因为我不知道下面有什么东西，我是说，这真的是个问题。我们这里有短吻鳄和各种生物。你根本不知道底下生活着什么
So there's times when you don't want to get in the water because it's brown. It's dirty. It's muddy and Along with that you get crawfish. Of course you get snakes you get frogs Silver eyes are good. Those are frogs. Red eyes are bad. Those are alligators. So my name is Sean Boudreau. I'm the vice president of Cajunavier Relief in Lactia, Louisiana. We're part of a civilian-led search and rescue organization that uses our own personal assets to help out and conduct rescues during disaster. Initially, my involvement with the Cajun Navy began in 2016 with a tropical system that came across the area that didn't even have a named storm associated with it, so it didn't get the recognition, it didn't get the media coverage, but it ended up being a thousand year flood.
所以有时你不想下水，因为它是棕色的。它是脏的，满是泥泞。伴随而来的还有小龙虾。当然还有蛇、青蛙。眼睛发银光的没问题。那是青蛙。眼睛发红的可不好。那是短吻鳄。我叫肖恩·布德罗。我是路易斯安那州拉克蒂亚“卡津海军救援队”的副总裁。我们是一个民间搜救组织，在灾难期间利用我们自己的个人资产来提供帮助并进行救援。最初，我与卡津海军的缘分始于2016年，当时有一场热带风暴席卷了该地区，它甚至没有一个命名风暴的代号，所以它没有获得认可，也没有获得媒体报道，但它最终演变成了一场千年一遇的洪水。
And the people who were being flooded out were not getting any help. Local authorities were doing the best that they could, but they had limitations and a lot of the folks down here in South Louisiana, well we have both in our backyards, you know, it's for instance Paradise. We do a lot of hunting fish and outdoorsy stuff and it just started on Facebook and we started caravansing to different areas that were flooded to start helping rescue folks. Once you start helping people and you see how effective you can be, just if you're there, just being there and being able to help immediately, it's very rewarding.
那些被洪水淹没的人得不到任何帮助。地方当局尽了最大努力，但他们有局限性，路易斯安那州南部这里的很多老乡，我们后院都有船，你知道的，比如天堂。我们经常进行狩猎、钓鱼和户外活动，这一切只是从Facebook开始的，我们开始组成车队前往不同的被淹区域，开始帮助救援群众。一旦你开始帮助人们，看到你能发挥多大作用，仅仅因为你在那里，只要身处现场并能够立即提供帮助，这就非常有意义。
My name is Emma Robbins and I am the executive director of the Navajo Water Project and what we do is help families on the Navajo Nation get access to hot and cold running water in their homes so that they have safe drinking water. I think being from a desert water is something that you just really value even more. I remember as a kid, my parents were like, don't waste water and it's something that I think most of us Navajos
我叫埃玛·罗宾斯，我是“纳瓦霍水资源项目”的执行总监，我们的工作是帮助纳瓦霍国（Navajo Nation）的家庭在他们的家中用上冷热水，让他们拥有安全饮用水。我认为作为一个沙漠人，你会更加珍视水。我记得小时候，我父母总是说，不要浪费水，我想这是我们大多数纳瓦霍人
have always grown up with is that you can't separate yourself from the earth. And water is a part of the earth. Navajos who are living on the Navajo Nation are 67 times more likely to not have running water than your average American. And 30% of our population does not have running water than your average American. And 30% of our population does not have running water or sanitation. And when we lose water, we lose everything. We lose our food source,
从小就知道的道理，那就是你无法将自己与大地剥离开来。水是大自然的一部分。居住在纳瓦霍国的纳瓦霍人无法用上自来水的可能性是普通美国人的67倍。我们有30%的人口无法用上自来水或卫生设施。当我们失去水时，我们就失去了切。我们失去了食物来源，
we lose something that keeps our body regulating and safe. You know, we lose our animals. And it breaks you down mentally. You know, you have to constantly think, and it breaks you down mentally. You know, you have to constantly think, where is my water coming from? Do I have enough money to buy bottled water? There are so many things that go along with not having water. It's not just, I can't drink anything. The rains that stick most in my mind are the sort of surreal ones where there's a storm
我们失去了维持身体调节和安全的东西。你知道的，我们失去了动物。这会在精神上摧毁你。你知道的，你必须不断思考，这会在精神上摧毁你。你知道的，你必须不断思考，我的水从哪里来？我有足够的钱买瓶装水吗？没有水会伴随着这么多问题。不仅仅是，我什么都喝不了。最留在我脑海中的雨是那种超现实的雨，上面有一朵暴雨
cloud on top and it's raining but it's an afternoon storm so the sun is at that four o'clock angle and they don't happen often, but when they do, the world takes this sort of surreal look. You know, there's bloom lighting off the streets, and it just, it looks very dreamlike. My name is Kyle Alvarado. I'm a lifelong El Paso Texas resident, and I create an aromatic liquid of the Creosow push that recreates the scent of desert rain. and aromatic liquid of the creosote bush that recreates the scent of desert rain.
云，正在下雨，但这是一场午后的暴雨，所以太阳处于下午四点钟的角度，这样的雨不常发生，但当它们发生时，世界就会呈现出一种超现实的外观。你知道的，街道上泛着微光，它看起来非常梦幻。我叫凯尔·阿尔瓦拉多。我是在埃尔帕索（德克萨斯州）生活了一辈子的人，我用三叶油柑灌木制作了一种芳香液体，能够重现沙漠雨的味道。以及一种能够重现沙漠雨气息的三叶油柑芳香液体。
When it's about to rain, it'll pass though the moisture will sort of wake up in the air and the resin in the leaves begins to activate and it starts to waft through the area and it's a great sort of preview of the coming rain. And then of course the rain comes and it washes everything clean and everything slows down a little bit and that creosote smell is still there. And
快要下雨时，水分会似乎在空气中苏醒，叶子里的树脂开始被激活，它开始在空气中飘荡，这是即将到来的降雨的一个极好的预兆。然后雨当然就下了下来，它把一切都冲洗得干干净净，一切都慢了下来，那种三叶油柑的气味依然存在。然后
once the rain stops and the waters begin to recede and things begin to dry up that creosote smell just as gently as it came in begins to sort of fade out. My name is Bonnie Toei. I'm a journalist and the author of the book Why We Swim. So a few years ago I went to Iceland to participate in this annual swim that happens on this island called Hamei and it's an honor of a man named Goodliger Fridthorsen who in 1984 was working as a fisherman when his boat capsized and he swam six kilometers over six hours in 41 degree water to safety. In 41 degree water, you and I would die within 20 to 30 minutes from hypothermia,
雨停了，水开始退去，万物开始干燥，那种三叶油柑的气味就像它悄然降临时一样开始渐渐消散。我叫邦妮·托伊。我是一名记者，也是《我们为什么游泳》一书的作者。几年前，我去冰岛参加了一场每年在名为海迈（Hamei）的岛屿上举行的游泳活动，这是为了纪念一个名叫古德利格·弗里兹索森（Goodliger Fridthorsen）的人。在1984年，他是一名渔民，当时他的船翻了，他在41华氏度的水温中游了六公里，历时六个小时才安全上岸。在41华氏度的水里，你和我会在20到30分钟内死于低体温症，
but he survived and turned out that he, in addition to being a great swimmer, his fat was two to three times normal human thickness, and it was like he was more like a seal than a human. So, good looks on. Good lookers swim. This one that takes place every year. It takes place, of course, in a swimming pool, because in the dead of winter, in March, in Iceland, it's this incredibly cold and dark, and people sign up for shifts that they can swim six kilometers in the pool. And so Iceland is one of those countries where there is an extremely high pools per capita.
但他活了下来。事实证明，除了是个游泳健将之外，他的皮下脂肪是正常人厚度的两到三倍，他看起来更像是一只海豹而不是人类。所以，向古德利格致敬。古德利格游泳赛。这个比赛每年都举办。它当然是在游泳池里进行的，因为在严冬的3月，在冰岛，这里异常寒冷和黑暗，人们报名轮班，以便能够在泳池里游完六公里。冰岛就是那种人均游泳池数量极多的国家。
Even in the tiniest town in Iceland, there's a public community pool. I think it was one of the historians at the History Museum on the island of heyme, she said, you know, in Iceland, the pool is our pub. Like, this is where we hang out. This is where we share stories. This is where we come together. And it was just this beautiful thing of like, you know, this annual tradition. To not just honor, loye loye is his nickname.
即使是在冰岛最小的小镇，也有一个公共社区游泳池。我想是海迈岛历史博物馆的一位历史学家说过，你知道的，在冰岛，游泳池就是我们的酒吧。这就是我们闲逛的地方。这就是我们分享故事的地方。这就是我们聚在一起的地方。这真是一件美好的事情，你知道的，这个年度传统。不仅仅是为了纪念“洛耶”（Loye，这是他的昵称，
Everyone calls him loye. But also to now it's taken on this role of trying to do something that you didn't know that you could do. My name is Nikki Halbin. I'm a writer and producer and I live in Brooklyn, New York. I've been canoeing on the Gohanis Canal many times and there's a wonderful group called the Gohanis Dredgers who take people out quite often. So, especially during lockdown, you know, I felt like I hadn't seen a tree or sat
大家都叫他洛耶）。而且现在它也承担起了一种尝试去做你原以为自己做不到的事情的角色。我叫尼基·哈尔宾。我是一名作家兼制作人，住在纽约布鲁克林。我曾在戈瓦纳斯运河（Gowanus Canal）上划过很多次独木舟，有一个叫“戈瓦纳斯清理队”（Gowanus Dredgers）的极好的组织经常带人们出去玩。所以，尤其是在封城期间，你知道的，我感觉自己好久没有见到一棵树，或者坐着
and looked at the water or done anything in so long. And the guy who runs the club said he was gonna go out and asked if I wanted to go, and I said, of course, and I talked to my friend Carolyn into going, even though her wife kept saying, it's such a bad idea, you're gonna fall in, it's so gross, it's so scary. It's toxic waste and it gets written about in the New York press in quite word details
看水，或者做任何事情了。运营这个俱乐部的那位A哥说他要出去，问我想不想去，我说当然想，我还说服了卡罗琳跟我一起去，尽管她的妻子一直说：“这真是个坏主意，你会掉下去的，太恶心了，太吓人了。”那是有毒废物，纽约媒体对此有很多生动的报道。
There's these myths that bodies have been found in it and that it was a mafia dumping ground It's really got a lot of Press about being filthy. It is a super fun site And I was like no one has ever fallen in, like what is totally safe and fine, like just kind of so she came along. And it was an extremely windy day and it was very cold and we were you know just kind of getting pushed up against the walls of the canal a bit. Oh we were you know paddling along, we were going away from the harbor. the walls of the canal a bit. But we were, you know, paddling along. We were going away from the harbor.
运河里曾发现过尸体，这里曾是黑手党的倾倒场，这些传言沸沸扬扬。关于它极其肮脏的报道真的很多。这是一个超级基金污染场地。而我说：“从来没有人掉下去过，这绝对安全而且没问题，”就那样……所以她就跟着一起来了。那天风非常大，天气很冷，你知道的，我们有点被吹得贴到了运河的墙壁上。哦，你知道的，我们在划着桨，我们正远离港口。被吹得贴到了运河的墙壁上。但你知道的，我们在划着桨。我们正远离港口。
Then someone called my name and I turned fairly quickly and it was like all of a sudden I was cold and in the canal and I was like oh oh, so embarrassed. I could immediately, so embarrassed. I had this whole vision in my head, because I had on like a leopard coat, and I have like white and gray hair. And all I could think was that someone was going to walk over the footbridge and like take a picture. And I mean, what a crazy thing
然后有人叫我的名字，我猛地回过头去，结果就像突然之间，我掉进了冰冷的运河里，我当时想，哦，哦，太尴尬了。我立刻感到无比尴尬。我的脑海里浮现出整个画面，因为我穿着一件豹纹大衣，而且我有白灰相间的头发。我脑子里想的全是，有人会走过那座人行桥，然后拍张照。我的天哪，太疯狂了
I think that there I would be on the front page of the New York Post or something like who's the you know Who's the great-haired leopard lady of the goon as canal and It was just like oh this is so bad like this is so bad and terrible I have not gone back. I will eventually It would be a shame to blame the water for my having fallen into it. My name is Alage Balte, and I am a professional figure skater, competed for Team Canada for over a decade, and spent most of my life in Montreal.
我想我会登上《纽约邮报》的头条什么的，比如“谁是戈瓦纳斯运河上那个顶着灰发的豹纹女士”之类的话。当时的感觉就是，哦，这太糟了，这太糟太可怕了。我再也没有去过那里。我最终还是会去的。把掉进水里这件事归咎于水本身，那就太遗憾了。我叫阿拉吉·巴尔特，我是一名职业花样滑冰运动员，曾为加拿大队效力十多年，大半生都在蒙特利尔度过。
When you're skating in the rain, it's like, it's so full of chemicals and paint and all these things that I don't necessarily associate it with water. But when you're outdoors on a lake, it's clear. It's like underneath me, there is, I don't know how many meters or feet of water that's not frozen. You know I had the opportunity to go on Lake Minowanka in Calgary, Banff, that
当你在雨中滑冰时，感觉就像是，里面充满了化学物质、油漆以及所有这些我不会自然而然与水联系起来的东西。但当你在户外的湖面上时，水是清澈的。感觉就像在我的脚下，有不知多少米或多少英尺没有冻结的水。你知道我有机会去卡尔加里的明尼万卡湖（Lake Minowanka），班夫，那
truly in a way changed my relationship with skating. Really. 80% of the lake was still open water. There was just a little area that had started freezing and actually the part that I skated on was only a couple inches thick and that's a bit scary but when it's thin like that it's it's it's magical because the sounds it makes is not something you ever hear when you skate. It sings. My name is Joy Bryant. I am an actor, a writer, and producer. So in 2018, we went to New Zealand for about two weeks. I kind of understood what I was getting myself into,
真的在某种程度上改变了我对滑冰的看法。真的。湖面80%仍然是开阔的水域。只有一个小区域开始结冰，实际上我滑冰的那部分只有几英寸厚，这有点吓人，但当冰层这么薄的时候，它是神奇的，因为冰发出的声音是你滑冰时从未听过。它在唱歌。我叫乔伊·布莱恩特。我是一名演员、作家兼制作人。所以在2018年，我们去了新西兰大约两个星期。我当时觉得自己对即将面临的事情有所了解，
and then I kind of did not understand what I was getting myself into. Like, I knew that we were gonna be rafting, but then in my mind, I just like, I didn't have a real frame of reference to really understand what that meant. And I'm such an uncomfortable swimmer, I don't really swim.
然后我又觉得自己根本不知道将要面对什么。比如，我知道我们要去漂流，但在我的脑海里，我只是——我没有真正的参考框架来真正理解那意味着什么。我对游泳极其不自在，我其实不太会游泳。
And I just remember like kind of like, trying to keep my anxieties, like just very quiet, because I'm just like, oh my god, this fucking boat. I can't I turn back now. I mean, I don't have to, I don't really have to do this, right? I don't have to do this. This is crazy.
我只记得我试图让自己的焦虑保持安静，因为我在想，“哦，天哪，这破船。我现在还能回头吗？我的意思是，我不必——我真的不必这么做，对吧？我不必这么做。这太疯狂了。”
It's gonna flip over, I'm gonna diamond a trap. It was like all these things going through my mind. I just sort of just kind of just fought through my anxieties and got my ass on the raft. And then, he wasn't bad. I'm just so grateful that I just shut up because once we got on the raft, I was like, oh, this is it. I'm good.
它会翻的，我会陷入绝境。各种各样的想法在我脑海中闪过。我只是强行克服了焦虑，把屁股挪到了木筏上。然后，其实也没那么糟。我很庆幸自己闭上了嘴，因为一旦上了木筏，我就觉得：“哦，就是这样。我很好。”
My name is Olivia Gonzalez. I live in Thornton, Colorado, and I am a professional mermaid. So at the Denver Aquarium, the way that we do shows is all with freediving, so we don't breathe off of any compressed air or anything like that. It's all breath holds. And we do a scripted show. And so it's a full-blown kind of little production. There's lines that we say under water. It's very choreographed. Kids love it. A little girl once came up and her eyes started at the bottom of my tail and trailed all the way up to my head. And she just was like, you're humongous. And I was like, awesome. You're humongous! That was like awesome!
我叫奥利维亚·、冈萨雷斯。我住在科罗拉多州桑顿，我是一名职业人鱼。所以丹佛水族馆的表演方式全都是靠自由潜水，我们不呼吸任何压缩空气或类似的东西。全靠憋气。我们表演的是有剧本的节目。所以这是一场成熟的小型制作。我们在水下有台词。这是经过精心编排的。孩子们非常喜欢。一个小女孩曾经走过来，她的目光从我尾巴的底部一直扫到我的头部。她只是说：“你太巨大了。”而我说：“太棒了。你太巨大了！”那感觉太棒了！
So when we're swimming it's really important while we're underwater and performing that we're not blowing bubbles out of our nose or out of our mouth because it just doesn't look great. And so the water will definitely kind of flood in your sinuses. And so when you get out you have to literally like kind of bend over and Just let it flood back out of your nose When I first started so when I did my audition. I had no idea that this was a thing I was in college at the time so afterwards I had to drive up To campus and I had a test in my environmental chem class and I'm sitting there taking this exam and all of this water is coming out of my nose. And I had no idea what was going on. I was freaking out, I'm trying to take this exam. So not the most glamorous thing.
所以当我们游泳时，在水下表演期间非常重要的一点是，我们不能从鼻子或嘴巴里吐出气泡，因为那看起来不太好。所以水肯定会涌入你的鼻窦。因此当你出水时，你必须字面意义上弯下腰，让水从你的鼻子重新流出来。我刚开始的时候——当我参加面试时。我完全不知道还有这回事。我当时还在上大学，所以结束后我不得不开车回校园，我有一节环境化学课要考试，我坐在那里参加考试，所有的水都从我的鼻子里流出来。我当时根本不知道发生了什么。我快急疯了，我还在努力应付这场考试。所以这并不是最光鲜亮丽的事情。
And yeah, definitely I would say one of the downfalls of the job. My name is Erica Bergman. I live in beautiful Victoria, British Columbia, and I'm a submarine pilot. Research submarines are actually called submersibles, and so our kind of submersible is entirely windows. It's like going to an aquarium and being wrapped by the glass in your own little bubble. It's really fun to take people down underwater, especially people who have perhaps made theories about what they think they're gonna find down there. At first they lose their minds, they get so excited. Everybody is so chipper and chatty and philosophizing down there,
是的，我绝对会说这是这份工作的缺点之一。我叫埃里卡·伯格曼。我住在美丽的英属哥伦比亚省维多利亚市，我是一名潜艇驾驶员。研究型潜艇实际上被称为潜水器，所以我们的这种潜水器完全由窗户组成。这就像去水族馆，被玻璃包裹在自己的小泡泡里。带人们下水潜航真的很有趣，特别是那些可能对他们在水下会发现什么做出过种种假设的人。一开始他们会兴奋得失去理智，变得非常激动。每个人在下面都兴高采烈、喋喋不休、高谈阔论，
if I can use that word. And after a few minutes, nobody is saying anything. Everyone is just staring out the window with their jaws wide open. And one of my favorite things to do is to help people realize the kind of distortion that the bubble creates.
如果我可以使用这个词的话。几分钟后，没有人说话了。大家都只是睁大眼睛死死盯着窗外。我最喜欢做的事情之一，就是帮助人们意识到气泡造成的这种视觉畸变。
So when you're in this spherical acrylic pressure hall, we call it, everything outside looks about 30% smaller than it really is. And so no matter where I am in the world, at some point during the dive, I know that I'll find a beer bottle. And you find a beer bottle and you show it to your passengers and they look at it and their eyes go big. They're like, what is that? A beer bottle for
所以当你身处这个我们称之为球形丙烯酸耐压舱的容器中时，外面的所有东西看起来比实际尺寸小大约30%。所以无论我身处世界何地，在下潜过程中的某个时刻，我知道我都会找到一个啤酒瓶。当你找到一个啤酒瓶并把它展示给乘客时，他们看着它，眼睛睁得老大。他们会问：“那是什么？那是给
Barbies? Is that a doll toy? You say, no, that's an actual beer bottle. And then all of a said in their sense of scale completely changes. And that reef that we were looking at or that sponge that we were looking at, that sponge that we were looking at, that's when the moment clicks for them. And then they realize that it's actually massive and it's taller than the submarine and it's wider than the submarine. And we're just this little pin prick of light
芭比娃娃准备的啤酒瓶吗？那是玩具娃娃的玩具吗？”你会说：“不，那是一个真正的啤酒瓶。”然后突然之间，他们的比例感彻底改变了。我们正在看的那个礁石或我们正在看的那块海绵，我们正在看的那块海绵，那一刻对他们来说醍醐灌顶。然后他们意识到它其实是巨大的，它比潜艇还要高，比潜艇还要宽。而我们只是这巨大生态系统拼图中的
looking at one little piece of this massive motif of an ecosystem. I'm sorry. This story was brought to you by Pop-Up Magazine Productions, written and produced by me, Haley Howell, along with Joy-Shan, Alyssa Eads, Ariel Mejia, and Elise Craig. Our editors are Derek Faggerstrom and Doug Magray. Our music and sound design is by Alex Overrington. Our creative director is Leo Jung. Rebecca Chu is our art director and Jackie Bates is our photography director. Lauren Smith is our director of operations. And we had production help from Al Shatz and Andy Spillman. Thanks so much for listening and don't forget to check out our visual field guide at popupmagazine.com. Popup Magazine has other field guides available, one on trees, and one on the night sky on their podcast and website.
一小块上观察着微小光点的一个小小探针。抱歉。本故事由 Pop-Up Magazine Productions 出品，由我、黑利·霍尔（Haley Howell）以及乔伊-珊（Joy-Shan）、阿丽莎·伊兹（Alyssa Eads）、阿里尔·梅希亚（Ariel Mejia）和埃利斯·克雷格（Elise Craig）共同撰写和制作。我们的编辑是德里克·法格斯特罗姆（Derek Faggerstrom）和道格·马格雷（Doug Magray）。我们的音乐和声音设计由亚历克斯·欧弗灵顿（Alex Overrington）负责。我们的创意总监是郑辽（Leo Jung）。丽贝卡·朱（Rebecca Chu）是我们的艺术总监，杰基·贝茨（Jackie Bates）是我们的摄影总监。劳伦··史密斯（Lauren Smith）是我们的运营总监。我们还得到了阿尔·沙茨（Al Shatz）和安迪·斯皮尔曼（Andy Spillman）的制作帮助。非常感谢您的收听，别忘了访问 popupmagazine.com 查看我们的视觉野外指南。《Pop-Up Magazine》还提供其他野外指南，一本关于树木，另一本关于夜空，均可在他们的播客和网站上找到。
Go get them and get to know Popup Magazine. They make amazing things at popupmagazine.com. When we come back and excerpt of a fun conversation I had with Gillian Jacobs and Deanna Reesonover from Periodic Talks about how to tell fun stories about boring things after this. And now an excerpt of Periodic Talks with Gillian Jacobs and Deanna Reeson over. Retrain me.
去获取它们并了解《Pop-Up Magazine》吧。他们在 popupmagazine.com 制作了不起的内容。接下来，我们将播出一段有趣的对话的节选，这是我与《Periodic Talks》的吉莉安·雅各布斯（Gillian Jacobs）和迪安娜·里森奥弗（Deanna Reesonover）聊的，内容是关于如何讲述关于无聊事物的有趣故事，稍后继续。现在是《Periodic Talks》节选，嘉宾是吉莉安·雅各布斯和迪安娜·里森奥弗。重新训练我。
There are rules in storytelling that you can intentionally play with or break altogether. And in 2020 at the start of the pandemic, you completely changed the format of your show in an episode called Roman Mars describes things as they are. So let's take a listen to how you started that episode.
讲故事是有规则的，你可以刻意运用它们，也可以彻底打破它们。2020年大流行刚开始时，你在名为《罗曼·马斯按原样描述事物》的一期节目中彻底改变了节目的形式。让我们来听听你是如何开始那一期节目的。
This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Hello beautiful homebound nerds. If I sound a little different, it's because I'm recording this at home. You might even hear some cars passing by. I'm not sick. Hopefully neither are you, but many of us are staying home so that we don't inadvertently become vectors to a virus whose impact we don't fully understand.
这里是《99%不可见》。我是罗曼·马斯。你好，美丽的居家书呆子们。如果我的声音听起来有点不同，那是因为我是在家里录音的。你甚至可能会听到一些汽车驶过的声音。我没生病。希望你也没有，但我们许多人都在家里呆着，这样我们就不会无意间成为某种影响尚未被完全理解的病毒的传播媒介。
This is the right thing to do. We are all part of one big ecosystem, and if any part of us gets sick, we all suffer. We are in this together. So my job in this world is to tell stories about all the thought that goes into the things most people don't think about. And since many of us are stuck at home, maybe alone, maybe lonely, I thought we'd spend some time exploring this place we call home together, just you and me.
这是正确的事情。我们都是一个巨大生态系统的一部分，如果我们中的任何人病了，我们都会受苦。我们休戚与共。所以我在这个世界上的工作，就是讲述人们没有去想的事物背后的所有思考。既然我们许多人都被困在家中，或许独自一人，或许感到孤独，我想我们不妨花点时间共同探索这个我们称之为家的地方，就你和我。
So I'm good. If your answer back out loud, I won't think you're weird. We talked earlier about the familiarity of the introduction and the intimacy and it works, it's like one of these things where it's such a payoff. Obviously, I don't want that to be a global pandemic to have this pay off, but I mean, it really is. It feels both so intimate and still so new. It's really, it's incredible.
所以很好。如果你大声回应我，我不会觉得你奇怪。我们刚才谈到了开场白的熟悉感和亲密感，它确实管用，这就像那种回报丰厚的事情。当然，我并不希望通过全球大流行来换取这种回报，但我的意思是，它确实如此。它既让人感到无比亲密，又依然那么新鲜。这真的很不可思议。
Well done, sir. Oh, thank you. Thank you. Yeah. So the things that are different there are, there's no music, like almost always after the night, I'm Roman Mars. There's a music hit. And I, so that, that show is completely dry.
干得漂亮，先生。哦，谢谢。谢谢。是的。所以那里不同的地方在于，没有音乐，几乎总是出现在“我是罗曼·马斯”之后的音乐高潮。我，所以那一期节目是完全没有音乐的。
There's no music. I was really looking for something different because it was, because we're a bunch of humans that make this show. And so we feel the world when we make it. And I don't know what the episode that was supposed to go on that week, but everything felt irrelevant. And so I was like, well,
没有音乐。我当时真的在寻找一些不同的东西，因为它是——因为我们是一群制作这个节目的普通人。所以我们在制作它时能感受到这个世界。我不知道那周本该播出哪一期节目，但一切都显得无关紧要。所以我当时想，好吧，
if the sort of idea, the central crux of the show is that we sit and describe things and talk about the interesting stories behind boring things, well then I'll just do it around here and then kind of encourage people to be inside because at that point, there was no mandate to be inside. It was the very, very beginning, but it was like people were like,
如果节目的某种核心理念、核心关键是我们要坐下来描述事物并讲述无聊事物背后的有趣故事，那我就在这里周围这样做，然后有点鼓励人们待在室内，因为当时还没有要求必须待在室内的强制令。那是最初、最初的时候，但感觉就像是人们
work was closing out. Like I think for the most part, I think my kids came home from school the Friday before, and you know, with no real, you know, like then they were like, they'll be back in two weeks or something like that. But I just wanted to reflect it, you know? And so, yeah, so that was the episode that was in my head. And so, that's what we made.
工作正在收尾。就像我记得大多数情况下，我的孩子们是在前一个星期五放学回家的，你知道的，当时并没有真正的，你知道的，就像他们当时说的那样，他们两周后就会回来之类的。但我只是想反映出这一点，你知道吗？所以，是的，这就是我脑海中的那一期节目。所以，这就是我们制作出来的东西。
And I really focused on trying to do that comfort and soothing. And also, a bit of the seduction of just like, okay, stay inside guys. I know you don't want to, but I really, really wanted to make a case for it because I believed in it. And that piece culminates with, I end up at my record player and I play a song, the only song you hear is a song like, I don't know what you call that, diagetic or something, but in the scene,
我真的很专注于努力做到那种舒适和抚慰。还有一点诱惑力，就像是，好吧，大家待在家里吧。我知道你们不想，但我真的很想为之辩护，因为我相信这一点。那段内容的高潮是，我最后走到我的唱片机前播放了一首歌，你唯一能听到的歌就像是——我不知道你怎么称呼那个，表现层声音还是什么的，但在场景中，
versus soundtrack versus diagetic sound, is like if you character turns on a radio in the play sound. Anyway, so it's diagetic. And I make this case for this musician I love, who has a heart condition, who can't go, we're gonna do this for him. And I asked his permission, I was like, okay, so when we get to the center of this thing,
对比原声带与表现层声音，就像如果你的角色在剧中打开收音机播放声音。不管怎样，所以它是表现层声音。我为我热爱的这位音乐家辩护，他有心脏病，他不能去，我们要为他这样做。我征求了他的同意，我说：“好吧，当我们到达这件事的核心时，
it's gonna be's cool with you. And he was pretty nice about it. But like the whole thing is a subtle case for us collectively carrying about each other by doing nothing. And so that's part of it too. So there's a few agendas that are going on there. But hopefully you just feel that intimacy and you just want to go on and ease into it.
这会对你没问题吧。”他对此表现得挺友善的。但整件事是对我们通过什么都不做来共同关爱彼此的一种微妙辩护。所以这也是其中一部分。所以那里有几个意图在同时进行。但希望你只是能感受到那种亲密感，然后就想顺其自然地融入其中。
This is the idea. We have another, we have this one last clip to set up and I'm really excited because I have a, I think, a question that I've been waiting to ask this whole time. So this is from that same episode and this is when you're kind of walking around your place and you're describing what you're seeing and the back stories that you see when you look around your space. Let's walk down the stairs. And we are entering the hall in his book at home. Bill Bryson wrote that no room has fallen further in history than the hall.
这就是这个想法。我们还有一个——我们有最后一个剪辑片段需要铺垫，我非常兴奋，因为我有一个我一直等着问的问题。所以这是来自同一期节目，这是当你四处走动，描述你所看到的东西，以及当你环顾四周时看到的背景故事。让我们走下楼梯。我们走进了他书中的大厅在家。比尔·布莱森（Bill Bryson）写道，在历史上，没有任何房间比大厅的地位下降得更多。
I always remember that line. I've been to Sterling Castle and Scotland a few times, and I love it there, especially the Great Hall, which has been painted a shocking and delightful butterry yellow since its restoration in the 1990s. We did a story about it a few years ago, you should check it out. It seems impossible that a hall like the one in Sterling Castle and the hall in your house have a shared origin, but they do. The hall used to be everything. From the Middle Ages, to about the 15th century, the hall was effectively the house, with a central hearth that people used to warm themselves and cook over. All activity took place there, awake and asleep. As soon as a second room was added to homes, the hall has been on a downhill slide.
我一直记着这句话。我去过苏格兰的斯特灵城堡好几次，我很喜欢那里，尤其是大厅，自从20世纪90年代修复以来，它被涂成了一种令人震惊且愉悦的黄油黄色。几年前我们做过关于它的故事，你应该去看看。斯特灵城堡里的那个大厅和你家里的那个大厅有着共同的起源，这似乎是不可能的，但它们确实有。大厅曾经是一切。从中世纪到大约15世纪，大厅实际上就是整个房子，里面有一个中央壁炉，人们用它来取暖和烹饪。所有的活动都在那里进行，无论是醒着还是睡着。一旦家里增加了第二个房间，大厅就开始走下坡路了。
Now, it is this dumb thing, a non-room room whose primary function is to connect other rooms. So, you know, pour one out for the hall. I love that so much. My question is, is it possible to train your brain to see stories everywhere? It totally is. And because I did it, I'm going to use, I don't want this to be obnoxious, but I'm going to use Roman Mars as a third person.
现在，它成了这个蠢东西，一个非房间的房间，其主要功能是连接其他房间。所以，你知道的，为大厅倒一杯酒致意吧。我太喜欢这个了。我的问题是：有可能训练你的大脑在各处都看到故事吗？完全可以。因为我做过这件事，我要用——我不想显得讨厌，但我要用第三人称来称呼罗曼·马斯。
But basically, Roman Mars is an aspirational figure who notices all things and cares about all things and reads every plaque. I am not Roman Mars all the time. Do you have a family nickname? Who are you really? No, I'm Roman to everybody, but still it's sort of, but that character of being, you know, like a student alert on it, you know, like, you know, I don't have that all the time.
但基本上，罗曼·马斯是一个有抱负的人物，他注意到所有事情，关心所有事情，并且阅读每一块牌匾。我并不是无时无刻都是罗曼·马斯。你有什么家庭昵称吗？你到底是谁？不，我对所有人来说都是罗曼，但它仍然有点像，但那种作为一个——你知道的，像一个时刻保持警惕的学生那样的角色，你知道的，你知道的，我并不是一直都有那种状态。
I have to really do have to, I do have to keep it going. And so, and sort of keep that curiosity alive. And I do that through the work. You know, like I don't know if I would always be like this. I mean, it's spilled out in different parts, but like it's the knowledge or the thought of like, of crafting something into a story that sort of trains you to think,
我真的必须去做——我确实必须保持下去。并且保持这种好奇心存活。我是通过工作来做到这一点的。你知道的，就像我不知道自己是否总是会这样。我的意思是，它已经渗透到不同的部分，但就像是把某种东西雕琢成一个故事的知识或想法，它会在某种程度上训练你去思考，
okay, so what's the story of this place? I'm like, what is this? And why have I heard, you know, like, hall or, you know, like, you know, like a Tammy Hall or whatever, I've heard this word before. And I know what a haul is in my house, and I wouldn't name it anything. You know, so just sort of like you notice those differences, and you go like, okay, so if there's a difference in incongruity or something I can't understand,
好吧，这个地方的故事是什么？我想，这是什么？为什么我听说过，你知道的，比如霍尔（Hall）或者，你知道的，比如坦慕尼厅（Tammany Hall）什么的，我以前听过这个词。我知道我家里有一个“大厅”（hall），但我不会给它起别的名字。你知道的，所以只要注意到这些差异，然后说，好吧，如果有什么不同、不一致或者我无法理解的东西，
well then there's a story there. There's a difference between that. That Delta is what the story is. And so just sort of be alert to those things and then have fun with them. And then sometimes they come to nothing. Like it's not all stories are great. But occasionally they are.
那么这里面就有一个故事。差异所在就是故事所在。所以只要对这些事情保持警惕，然后从中找到乐趣。有时它们最终什么都不是。就像并非所有故事都是伟大的。但偶尔它们确实是。
And sometimes it's just in the way that you tell them. And sometimes it's about the passion of telling it. You know, like I think that the whole story is like, you know, like you could tell it kind of boringly. You know, but I, you know, but I turn the hall into a person, you could tell it kind of boringly, but I turn the hall into a person that you pour one out for. That's part of the process of it is to make it interesting.
有时这只在于你讲述它们的方式。有时这关乎讲述时的热情。你知道的，就像我认为整个故事是这样的，你知道的，你可以用一种有点无聊的方式来讲述它。你知道的，但是我会——但我把大厅变成了一个你可以为之倒酒致意的人，你可以用一种有点无聊的方式来讲述它，但我把大厅变成了一个你可以为之倒酒的人。这就是让它变得有趣的过程的一部分。
But yeah, you definitely can just read plaques and look down a lot and you can do it. It's like, usually engaging with the belt world usually involves some disengagement with actual humans. But you can do it. I was just a little bit of the conversation that I had with Killian and Diana. There's a ton more from me and you will also learn about eels from Pedro Pascal on the latest episode of Periodic Talks.
但话又说回来，你绝对可以通过阅读牌匾和经常往下看，然后你就能做到这一点。这就像是，通常与物质世界的互动往往伴随着与真实人类的一些脱节。但你能做到这一点。这只是我与吉莉安和迪安娜对话的一小部分片段。我还有更多内容，在最新一期的《Periodic Talks》中，你还将从佩德罗·帕斯卡（Pedro Pascal）那里了解到关于鳗鱼的知识。
Go get it! 99% of visible is Delaney Hall, Kurt Colessted, Vivian Le, Sean Rihau, Chris Baroubaix, Joe Rosenberg, Lashemba Dawn, Christopher Johnson, Emmett Fitzgerald, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are a part of the Stitcher and Sirius XM podcast family now headquarters at 6 blocks north in the Pandora building in beautiful uptown oakland california. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on facebook you can tweet at me at Roman Mars and show at 99pi org or on instagram and read it too you can find links to other Stitcher shows I love, including periodic talks,
去听吧！99% Visible 的成员有 Delaney Hall、Kurt Colessted、Vivian Le、Sean Rihau、Chris Baroubaix、Joe Rosenberg、Lashemba Dawn、Christopher Johnson、Emmett Fitzgerald、Sophia Klatsker，以及我 Roman Mars。我们现在是 Stitcher 和 Sirius XM 播客家族的一部分，总部位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心潘多拉大厦以北 6 个街区。你可以在 Facebook 上找到节目并加入关于节目的讨论，你可以在 Twitter 上 @ Roman Mars，节目账号是 99pi org，或者在 Instagram 上关注并阅读。你还可以找到我喜爱的其他 Stitcher 节目的链接，包括 Periodic Talks，
as well as every past episode of 99PI and 99PI.org. This is a Stitcher, a Stitcher podcast, a stature podcast from Sirius XM. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及 99PI 和 99PI.org 的所有往期节目。这是一个来自 Stitcher、Stitcher 播客、Sirius XM 的播客。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。